if we remove the definition of
psychopath away from the the kind of
more clinical settings to an everyday
life kind of scenario Psychopaths tend
to have quite a few positive
characteristics going for them they tend
to be assertive
they don't procrastinate they focus on
the positives of situations they don't
take things personally they don't beat
themselves up when things go wrong and
they're very cool under pressure now
those kinds of characteristics and can
actually really help us get along in
life so let's exert sir give you a very
simple example if you like the Nike
slogan just do it there's a psychopathic
slogan for you if ever there was one
Psychopaths do not procrastinate
Psychopaths if they want something they
go for it and they go for it now now
actually I mean I I write in the book
that that actually Top Sportsman are
very high in certain psychopathic
characteristics now let me just go
through them
you've got ruthlessness you've got
fearlessness you've got mental toughness
you've got coolness under pressure
you've got the ability to focus
remorselessly on a goal I mean these
things are straight out of the sports
psychology textbooks in many ways so you
know anyone from from from top golfers
to to top cyclists to top boxers to top
athletes and they are going to be high
on these psychopathic characteristics
now where we start getting into the
realms of criminal Psychopaths is when
we look at natural aggression levels and
perhaps natural levels of intelligence
if you've got those characteristics
right there that I've told you about and
you happen to be naturally violent and
you also happen to be naturally stupid
not a very politically correct word
there but you happen to be low in
intelligence then your prospects to be
perfectly honest with you are not going
to be that great ok you're going to wind
up smacking a bottle over someone's head
in a bar and you are going to wind up in
prison pretty quickly ok
however if you've got those traits I've
just mentioned to you and you are not
naturally violent and
you are also intelligent then it's a
different story altogether then as the
famous Reuters headline once once
mentioned you are more likely going to
make a killing in the market than
anywhere else